This episode of Dnews is brought to you by
Ting: Mobile that makes sense.
Science says our smartphones are a reflection
of ourselves.
So what does it mean if I've dropped mine
in the toilet 3 times?
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - and I've said
it before, I'll say it again: Everything is
disgusting.
Especially your cellphone.
It's like a tiny bacteria delivery device.
And a new study shows that those bacteria
- are indeed a reflection of you.
A group of researchers from the University
of Oregon, sequenced microbes from the index
fingers and thumbs of 17 subjects, as well
as microbes from the surface of their smartphone
touchscreens.
The goal was to see if our favorite and most
widely used possessions resemble us, microbially
speaking.
And it turns out - they do.
Researchers found that 82% of the most common
bacteria found on the subjects' fingers - were
also present on their phones.
Meaning your personal microbiome - which is
the specific collection of bacteria that's
unique to every person - closely resembles
the bacteria on your phone.
The three most commonly found ones were Streptococcus,
Staphylococcus, and Corynebacterium, which
is a mostly harmless bacteria that lives on
human skin - but has been known to cause diptheria,
an upper respiratory tract illness.
Interestingly, they also found that women
seem to share more microbial similarity with
their phones - than men do.
Although there's no current explanation on
why that may be.
Now it's kind of obvious that our cell phones
would match us, since most of us are glued
to them all day long - but the study does
have some interesting implications.
Specifically, it paves the way for potentially
using someone's personal effects as a means
of monitoring their health.
Not only is it non-invasive, it doesn't really
require direct participation from the person.
Meaning it could be a fast - and easy way
- to conduct large-scale microbial studies,
analyze our exposure to biological threats,
or screen the microbes of hospital and healthcare
workers.
Currently, 1 in every 20 patients at a healthcare
facility, will contract a hospital-acquired
infection at some point.
So being able to screen those people - and
their caretakers - could prevent the spread
of disease, as well as thousands of hospital-related
deaths.
Sounds like a pretty good deal!
And speaking of good deals, if you do have
a cell phone - which of course you do, cause
it's 2014 - then you gotta check out Ting.
Ting is a new mobile phone service that puts
the power back in your hands, AND saves you
money in the process.
With Ting, there are no yearly contracts,
no plans, and no hidden fees.
And you only pay the data and minutes you
actually use.
A novel concept!
But a good one.
All of your monthly bills come with complete
transparency - so you can see exactly what
you're getting charged for.
They also have great 24/7 customer service,
so if you have any questions - you can call,
and you're guaranteed to get a real live person
on the other line.
Did I mention that it's cheap?
If you hit up dnews.ting.com and click on
their Savings Calculator, you can see just
how much Ting would save you over the next
2 years.
98% of customers save money just by switching
- so what do you have to lose?
Hit up dnews.ting.com - and remember, every
visit to that link helps support the show.
In the meantime, if you have questions, comments,
anything you wanna say about this episode
- just leave em in the comments below.
Otherwise, thanks for watching!